we are now ready to classify proteins
into family using hidden markov models
let's assume that we are given multiple
alignment of
already known members of the protein
family
and that we have constructed hmm based
on this family
and now a new protein comes in and we
want to decide
whether it belongs to the given protein
family
the easiest thing to do is simply apply
viterbi algorithm to find an optimal
hidden path
and decide whether this protein belongs
to a family depending on
probability threshold for this protein
so that's what's shown on this slide
and if this probabilistic threshold
uh ex satisfied then we classify protein
as belonging to this family and extends
the alignment of proteins in this family
as shown in this slide
so to do this classification we need to
construct
the turbine graph for the given hmm
diagram
please note that we have not discussed
yet how to construct
the viterbi graph for an hmm diagram for
example
how many rows this viterbi graph will
have
well as before each the number of rows
in the viterbi graph should be equal to
the number of
states in this hmm diagram so
large number of rows and here i showed
the viterbi graph and i took a liberty
to assign every single column to every
state
hmm is passing through does it make
sense so
the number of columns in the viterbi
graph shown here
equal to the number of visited states
there is one problem with this viterbi
graph
we don't know in advance of what will be
the number of visited states when we
look at the newly sequenced protein
and therefore it's not even clear how to
construct this graph
for example in this case it has two
deletion states but how do we know
this before we constructed the hmm
the viterbi graph and therefore we
should actually try to think about how
to construct
the viterbi graph uh based with the
number of columns
based on the number of emitted symbols
something that we know
rather than the number of visited states
something that we don't know in the case
of
silent states such as deletion states
and therefore by definition the number
of
columns in the viterbi graph should be
equal to the number
of emitted symbols which means it should
be smaller
than the number of columns in this
erroneously constructed viterbi graph
but he is correctly constructed with
orbit graph
every time we move to the deletion state
and do not
emit the symbol we actually transform
the edge
into vertical edge within the same
column in this case
the number of columns in the viterbi
graph
equal to the number of emitted symbol
and the
viterbi graph then is well defined
the only thing we need to add is the
zero column
that contains only silent states for
technical details
so we just reduced
the problem of alignment to visa profile
hmm to the following problem
a line in new sequence to a family of
aligned sequences
using a profile hmm the input
is a multiply alignment a string text
estrous whole theta describing maximum
fraction of
insertions per column and the pseudo
account
sigma an output is an optimal hidden
path
emitting text in the profile hmm
h denoted hmm alignment
theta sigma let's take a look
at the hidden paths constructed in the
hmm diagram
and of course this hidden path
correspond to a path
in the usual alignment graph that we
considered before
the question then arises we just
describe a rather complex decoding
algorithm for constructing the hidden
parts
in the hmm but wouldn't be easier to
just construct the same alignment path
using the traditional alignment
technique or in other words
have i wasted your time indeed the
recurrence for the viterbi algorithm
is very similar to the recurrence for
the traditional sequence alignment
for the viterbi algorithm the score at
the node
equal to the maximum of three scored of
the preceding state
for the alignment again the score of the
node
equal to the maximum of three scores of
its predecessor
so it indeed looks like i wasted your
time
however notice that the choice of
alignment path
is now based on varying transition and
emission probabilities
between different columns and therefore
this
individual scoring parameters allows us
to detect subtle similarities using hmm
similarities that the traditional
sequence alignment often
misses